salamualikum' what amateur a better care
to bother the citizen dear friends I'm
not gonna hold you guys much long just a
couple of minutes very important
there is room is going that there might
be an absolutely lockdown within 48
hours what this means is that everybody
is gonna be told just as they did in
Italy in Spain and different parts of
the world to stay in nobody's coming out
unless necessary of course now Robin
says there's a lot of things to be
learned from this I'm gonna keep it very
simple and short this is a very very
urgent message not because there's a
lockdown happen in 48 hours but there's
a bigger bigger thing that we all have
to understand and this might sound a bit
cliche but it's fundamental for us to
understand this a lot of the times we
are told that when it comes to
obligations as Muslims that we should do
we are told for example sometimes we
will say you know what
I'm busy to pray yeah I've got the
children etc it's hard I need to earn
money I don't have a break yeah I need
to go and do this and do that I'm not
feeling well etc operate later or making
up all of these excuses listen to me
carefully very very carefully this is a
reminder to myself first all of those
factors work this that shopping etc
right now in 40 hours what that means
it's gonna be a absolute lockdown and
what that means is that we're all going
to be in our own houses with our family
members which I've done a video in
Salaam which you guys should check out
about kinship this is also forced us to
be in our family houses with our own
family members to fix kinship but that's
another issue what's really important is
that when we're going to be in our
houses there is none of these excuses I
have to go work yeah I have to wake up
in the morning I'm gonna be busy with
this and that and blah blah blah all
those fun now the question that needs to
be asked is the following for those who
were not praying and for those who are
not doing their obligations all those
excuses external in excuses and
influences are gone you are at home with
your family members maybe for the next
two weeks maybe for a month maybe for
two months maybe for free mums we do not
know now if you have come to the
realization
that you're still not praying when
you're at home then the question that
needs to be asked is the following was
it really the early morning shifts the
late night shifts the money that you
have to provide which is coming from all
anyways as an excuse not to pray kids
family the step mom and dad have to do
this football etc blah blah catching up
with the girls or is it that there's
something internal going on that's
preventing it from praying because all
these factors have stopped now so that
means you have no excuse not to pray and
if you're not praying that means all of
those external things were nothing but
an excuse brothers and sisters this is
fundamental this is so important for us
to realize this as-salam our
organization we really want to convey
this message to you guys please for the
sake of allah subhanaw taala realize
allah subhanho wa taala says that we
send a smaller calamity before the
greater one meaning this small thing has
come this virus God knows was going to
do how many people is going to kill we
don't know we're not trying to scare
people have to our trust in allah
subhanho wa taala in 1990 there was a
same issue that happened in spain and it
killed 30 million people may Allah
protect us from that however this is a
realization for us all to understand
Allah is the one that's in control
return back to him at this time if
you're in your houses please please
please if you are not turning to your
Lord if you're not praying doing estephe
are given in charity whatever it may be
being kind to your spouse's whatever it
may be do cook these towards him reading
looking and reflecting reading the
hadith if you're not doing this prophets
and sisters have no doubt that all those
other excuses those factors that you
thought was stopping you from doing good
deeds or getting cross that Allah was
nothing but an absolute excuse that
Allah has moved up the way and you're in
your houses you have not for nothing to
do but reflect you're working at home
now it's time to reflect and at these
times if we do not change one lie I do
not know what else can change us one lie
if you're not going to change at this
moment of time I don't know
it is a reminder for me to you as allah
subhanaw taala says in the quran
reminder benefits a believer brothers
and sisters please let's use this we
don't know if this will be the last time
we see each other we don't know anything
can happen so please turn to salah turn
back to your lord who might even cut
tops out and i'll finish on this allah
subhanho wa taala
raised this nation is ummah with the
quran and the sunnah and if we turn our
backs on it allah would humiliate us so
brothers and sisters hope this virus
goes away and we all protected special
our elderly but just reflect because you
have no other choice but because you've
got a long couple of days or weeks or
months of reflection do some double
indeed it might be a key that will save
you assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to from salam studios or keep you
guys updated with event and current
issues as corner